à ma gauche julien marie dit zhu
l'artiste français le plus écouté sur
les plates formes de streaming musical
avec 600 millions d' écoute sur deezer
apple spotify le plus regardé sur
youtube avec 600 millions de vues plus
gros vendeur d'albums en france cette
année
à ma droite tarik benhabiles andrieu aka
a démarré n os les deux frères de pnl
disques d'or et 13 millions d' écoute
sur deezer ou moins d'une semaine pour
leur dernier album dans la légende et le
million de vues atteint 14 heures pour
le clip n'a un record sur youtube
deux nouveaux poids lourds du rap
français mais comment ils en sont
arrivés là et pourquoi ils rencontrent
un succès pareil
et surtout pourquoi une phase iib autant
que ce soit dans n'importe quel sens
pourquoi
avant toute chose je pas abordé le
contenu musical de chaque artiste
chacun est libre d'aimer ou pas ce qu'il
veut l'objectif de ce pop-up c'est pas
d'analyser leur musique mais de
comprendre pourquoi et comment qui sont
déjà devenus cultes est une des
premières raisons c'est l'authenticité
chacun dans leur style
ils savent se montrer fidèle à ce qu'ils
sont depuis le début prenons jul pour
commencer un originaire de marseille il
met sa ville et sa région à l'honneur
dans la plupart de ses clips et ses
textes étaient également participer ses
potes depuis toujours dans beaucoup de
ces projets pour pennel on retrouve
presque le même schéma originaire de la
cité des tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes a
des mots et n os rendent hommage à leur
quartier régulièrement en occupe da on
les voit même accroché leurs disques
d'or dans la mjc des tarterets et leur
entourage est essentiel à leur réussite
et leur vision du monde un double fameux
qu élèves pour que la famille ultra
présent dans les textes
après pour aimer fortement quelqu'un ou
quelque chose c'est plus facile si on
peut s'y identifier et pour s'identifier
à un sujet il faut qu'il soit crédible
réel
on a besoin d'avoir des idoles pour nous
accomplir et nous construire comme le
dit le philosophe michel lacroix jul il
est issu d'un milieu populaire et savant
pas une vie un érable sombrer quotidien
il est fier de son accent marseillais et
ne change pas de look ni d'habitude avec
le succès mais c'est définit lui-même
comme un rappeur en claquettes il
déroulé en twingo et continuent à boire
de l'oasis au pnl c'est pareil les deux
frères sont d'anciens dealers et restent
fidèles à leur origine que ce soit dans
les textes ou les clips de leurs
chansons racontent leurs anciens
quotidiens etc transparence et sans
artifice et font part de sincérité de
leurs problèmes
il faut pas fantasmer leurs fans avec
des jacuzzis ou des bimbos qui ne
fréquentent pas le triptyque de clips
tout juste achevée la nasa onizuka men
et qui raconte une embrouille de dealers
de cité et même presque quasi
autobiographique mais c'est pas tout 1
ce qui les rend authentique aux yeux du
public
c'est aussi leur indépendance ni l'un ni
l'autre d'intégrer un gros label les
deux au fond des le leur jul avec d'or
et de platine et pnl avec qu elle est
fréquente
par contre on n'est pas vraiment sûr
même style graphique de cette manière
les deux artistes sont libérés de toute
contrainte artistique pouvant être
imposées par les majors et gèrent leur
business
à leur façon pnl et djoum ont créé une
vraie mythologie à travers leurs clips
et leurs textes thématiques récurrentes
références multiples look chimiques
tous ces éléments en les combinant créé
un vrai univers dans lesquels les fans
peuvent se plonger et cette mythologie
que les deux construisent et se base
aussi sur des références des références
communes à toute une génération
qui nous permet de les rendre plus
proche de nous pour plc simba les stars
de fou des années 1990 n'oublie dragon
ball gt haut et ça contraste avec leur
image d'aix dealers et se dévoilent leur
sensibilité renforçant encore plus le
principe d' authenticité 12 lui va
parler des sujets beaucoup plus direct
et va pas hésité à aborder des
problématiques directement lié au
quotidien des gens l'amour les galères
maison bruit avec les potes
le manque d'argent la cité voilà le mec
est vrai et sincère et son audience peut
facilement se reconnaître dans ce texte
après il ya aussi la vidéo depuis
l'avènement de mtv dans un premier temps
et l'explosion de youtube ces dernières
années le clip est devenu presque aussi
important que la chanson est dans ce
domaine
d'où les pn elles ont aussi quelques
similitudes on peut classer leurs clips
en deux catégories entre lesquels il
alterne presque chaque fois d'un côté
l'équipe réalisé au quartier au milieu
des leurs pour un petit peu asseoir leur
street cred et de l'autre il ya des
concepts vidéos qui font encore une fois
leur singularité
jul par exemple céder quasi court
métrage parfois drôles parfois plus
sérieux mais toujours à des années
lumières des clichés du rappeur busta
qui boit du people trunk et ce fait
marqué dessus une cohésion parfaite avec
ses textes et sa musique plus festive
qui renforce son positionnement pnl eux
ils ont dû pas mal potassé le guide du
routard parce qu'ils voient dans des
décors assez paradisiaque aux quatre
coins du monde
namibie island japon italie c'est des
images qui sont souvent très belle
réalisé évidemment par leurs potes mais
ce que lfg des images sont ils me disant
tu daignes du coup du corps au cloud rap
un côté un peu planant qui se dégage qui
colle bien la nostalgie leur musique et
leurs lyrics une autre raison leur
succès ça leur productivité
on a l'impression de l'avoir tout le
temps pénale a sorti deux albums en
moins de deux ans le monde chico 17
titres et dans la légende 18 titres
c'est déjà beaucoup mais jul fait encore
plus fort déjà le type fait tout un
production écriture c'est un autodidacte
et le nombre de son pull assorti et
vertigineux sur l'excellent site genuis
on peut trouver plus de 200 chansons
différentes alors que le mec à tout
juste 27 ans et dans une interview et
revendique même avoir écrit 400 autres
chansons avant 2012 d'ailleurs à ses
débuts jude ça donnait ça
[Musique]
mais quand la sirène dans les casseroles
pnl rap est aussi avant d'avoir un style
et une dégaine aussi marqué j'te fais
pareil mois l'an passé sur le terrain
le cul entre deux bancs en ne baissant
pas leur rythme de production ils
permettent à leurs fans de découvrir de
nouveaux morceaux fréquemment sans
qu'ils aient le temps de s'ennuyer ou de
cela ça c'est des similarités
mais là où jouent les pénales sont
clairement opposés c'est dans leur
rapport aux médias et plus précisément
dans l'image qu'ils souhaitent donner
deux jours ils jouent la carte de la
popularité il a un mec normal qui fait
du rap normal et c'est ça qui cartonne
pas d'artifices s'adresse régulièrement
et directement à ses fans et ses réseaux
sociaux niveau proximité avec son public
qu'il suffit de voir comment il agit sur
les réseaux sociaux il répond à
énormément de commentaires
avec plus ou moins de fautes
d'orthographe il propose des live où il
explique par exemple comment il va créer
un morceau voilà il fait aussi des
passages télé même s'ils sont rares ils
squattent des studios de skyrock
il donne des interviews il est sans
filtre il propose un rap divertissant
sans ses tarifs et les gens sans aucune
prétention et en se moquant des
critiques et cette force ça devient un
paradoxe
en agissant de manière ordinaire dans le
milieu du rap français il en devient
extraordinaire il casse les codes en
vigueur et débarque comme un ovni
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle
pén elle fait également figure
d'extraterrestre dans le rap game mais
eux ils viennent une planète encore
différente à la manière des daft punk ne
font aucune apparition publique
aucune interview et cultive le mystère
donne les informations au compte gouttes
et n'apparaissent dans aucun média
volontairement on sait pas grand chose
d'eux et ce mystère il alimente les
discussions de fans avec des
interprétations et des théories en tout
genre et seulement le magazine américain
assez connu de faille d'heure qui en a
fait une couverture et une interview et
même sur skyrock
ils sont pas déplacés pour leur planète
rap laissant le studio à leur pote tu
élèves et des décors diverses rappelant
l'univers de leur album et ce côté
mystérieux à cette fascination qui
rentrent en pnl elle est accentuée par
leurs clips quasi mystique
en revanche malgré tout ça ils savent
quand même mettre la communauté à
l'honneur cette diversité ce renouveau
c'est une très bonne chose
en europe france hélas rarement semblé
aussi variée et de qualité il existe de
nombreux artistes très différents qui
arrive à créer des projets des univers
singuliers
tous ont toujours une belle audience et
de manière indépendante ce qui
déstabilise parfois les majors qu'on
aime ou qu'on n'aime pas un autre débat
mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que je
voulais pnl et ils ont des manières
d'aborder les choses qui sont très
proches
malgré les apparences mais avec des
différences assez forte qui les rendent
uniques et cette tendance pense à l'otan
de si dès qu'elle soit avec une
proximité forte chedjou - mysticisme
grancher pnl c'est une tendance qui ne
touchent pas que l'europe est qu'à
regarder les youtube heure par exemple
j'espère que ce pour quoi vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à le partager mettez moi
dans les commentaires sous dépensés et
c'était pas lâcher un pouce aussi pour
le référencement la vidéo ça aide on se
retrouve très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo love peace ciao
[Musique]